hey guys it's vs boy 89 and today I'm
gonna be watching this video could try
not to suffer hardest addition and well
I'm already scared because I'm really
bad at not suffering I mean like I
suffer at everything but hey yeah let's
get on with the video shall we man what
a [ __ ] trihard so the hottest anime
to come out this year thus far as
finally come to an end and everyone is
talking about it 3-0 anime of 2016 it's
the new season of Everybody Loves
Raymond yeah REM is the second coming of
[ __ ] Christ apparently and as with any
big show the re0 hype train has been
running wild for the past two seasons
but how well does it stand up to the
hype that it's got in this year well if
you've read the title of this video you
probably already know but let's go down
to single sentence doesn't sum up my
entire printing right we're introduced
to the world of re0 a stereotypical
fancy world complete with everything you
need from your usual fancy settings
let's see do we have bright colors yeah
magic yeah humanoid beings that look
like animals
Jack chivalrous nice to look like the
below in k-pop groups definitely check
an innocent princess to serve as the
main love interest Jack an array of
waifu's out of way better but have no
chance of winning
chug a sexy cat lady you're attracted to
who you're told has a penis
check and an unlikely hero who's
transported to set world
yes I'm likely hero this time is Subaru
a self-proclaimed otaku who's introduced
this war to do some thing by some time
but the twist is that he has the power
to reset his life to a point a time
every time he dies kind of like a video
game exactly like a video game the reset
mechanics even come complete with
checkpoints in the form of a buff
Irishman offering you apples every time
Subaru makes the pass and achievements
well actually council the checkpoint is
some thing defined by some one and
that's pretty much all I could say
because I have about as much of an idea
of what the central themes of the plot
are in the last episode as I did in the
first episode but I'll get back to that
see what we zero is about it's a journey
that Subaru takes to get past whatever
obstacle comes his way
often having to die repeatedly to figure
out the correct thing to do so you see
although
comments you see on the internet telling
suru to [ __ ] kill yourself they're
just trying to offer some form of
genuine advice probably literally
[ __ ] kill yourself though the first
thing that really stands out by the show
is it's surprisingly dark and gory
content which contrasts the saturated
colors and bright tone these series
initially gives off yet it manages to
pull this off without ever feeling too
out of place or edgy it's not teen angst
we're dealing with there and it's not
violence for the sake of violence either
it does well to highlight the fact that
the act of dying is not a pretty thing
showing us why Subaru doesn't want to
off himself whenever there's just the
slightest hint of trouble but the series
truly starts to shine during the second
half when the mechanics of the time
reset are used to the greatest effect
and what effect is this Rosaire does a
wonderful job of setting up the worst
possible scenarios for Subaru to go
through as we see him suffer episode
upon episode with seemingly nothing ever
going right for him and every decision
he makes leading to more despair which
is luckily signaled by very useful sound
effects every time something bad happens
in case the viewer couldn't tell that
the bloodied corpse on the floor with
his guts filled out everywhere probably
a sign of something bad is about to
happen but thanks for letting me know
anyway anime it was really useful what
what's happening No
no it's all about a suffering that
Subaru goes through because people we
cares for our murder torture and it goes
through some horrific events and it
works because thanks to the time reset
you can put your character through
multiple traumatic events with no
consequence to the overall plot and re0
definitely pushes this concept to the
limit every mechanic is present to
invoke the most drama possible leading
to some very emotional and shocking
moments throughout the show because even
though we know that everything can be
reset upon death it doesn't detract from
the fact that subaru has to experience
all these things happening to him and
that everyone aside for him doesn't know
that the events can be reset as this is
their reality and they act that way so
while the mechanics do work like a game
it certainly never does feel like one as
it's never as simple as just pressing a
reset button on the menu we really feel
from as we essentially see a character
mentally and physically beaten down
repeatedly but it does make for one hell
of a gripping ride even if I don't know
what kind of [ __ ] he did to deserve all
this happened to him seeing Subaru
slowly transform from the bright
optimistic person he was originally to
the full-on mental breakdown is what
really makes it such an endearing watch
as morbid as that sounds as a character
Subaru whether you think he's likable or
not is what carries this show for all
intents and purposes the world he
started into is a pretty cliche fantasy
world with cliche characters to boot but
Subaru himself is a breath of fresh air
from the usual otaku protagonist who is
transported into a fantasy world where
becomes a hero of some sort with no
trouble at all while he considers
himself a hero initially in a grand
scheme of things Subaru is almost
entirely powerless compared to everyone
else he has a tremendous amount of
character flaws and he slowly realizes
he is not the grand hero he thinks he is
when the show makes it abundantly clear
by the amount of trials he has to go
through to achieve anything
his only weapons are the knowledge he
gains on every cycle and his positive
outlook on life which is shown that 90
percent of the time means absolute dick
were those times when everything does
come together and things work it's
remarkably satisfying and the series
does a great job of making you feel that
you ride the roller coaster of emotions
with Subaru and it's one hell of a ride
with many ups and downs which brings me
to my main criticism of the show because
after going through that exhilarating
ride after seeing Subaru suffer time and
time again learn from his mistakes and
satis finally find the correct path
through the obstacles after all that you
finally get off
suffering train and look back at a ride
you just took and you're left wondering
what exactly was the point of all that
looking a bit closer at the series as a
whole ask yourself this what exactly
were the central themes of the plot what
was reesy row actually about I mean [ __ ]
in one show we have the Antiques
Roadshow Hayate the [ __ ] Butler CSI
mansion
Rambo the British royal family fantasy
Isis and The Adventures of Moby Dick
without anything really tying it all
together there is nothing really driving
the plot for Subaru aside from worship
Amelia and try not to die you could
maybe argue that the royal selection and
the witch's resurrection is the central
driving force but those are only really
background events to everything that is
actually going on and in the entire
series no real progress is made towards
either of those plot points the entire
plot seemed to be completely reactive
rather than proactive at the beginning
of each arc you really had no idea where
the plot was going and that includes
what could happen in the second season
instead it felt more like the author was
thinking of every possible way to
trigger some events make Subaru suffer
as much as possible it never feels as
natural as other dark shows that sees
characters go through hardship because
as I said there's no real rhyme or
reason for the suffering as everything
that happens is entirely reactive in the
end you just kind of expect something to
go wrong to make Subaru suffer because
why the hell nice happens every time
before but apart from that we're cool
right I mean all the characters are fine
and everything like all of us he watched
it has no problems with anything the
characters did or anything right no no I
want the other thing come on I know it's
just dangling oppa took you to a movie
you're just once please I am here oh yes
as far as characters goes most of them
have their own unique quirks and tropes
that were nothing over we hadn't seen
before but the variety of character
interactions were enough to keep them
from being bland and unforgettable
without the need of being fleshed out
but giggle kissing Rambis girl how dare
you don't recognize the brilliance that
is RAM rare his life rub is love just
look at her Reesie arrow more like rm0
am i right well of course Ram is best
girl she is winner by [ __ ] defaults
because no other character even had the
chance of doing something of any
significance apart from her which is a
shame because the cast is filled with
plenty of as interesting if not more so
characters that never got the
amount of screen time has rammed it
besides the amount of Beatrice we got in
the second half of the show was
disgustingly non-existent I suppose but
this never really was about the rest of
the cast as witch shows like steins gate
you'll always have problems with
developing characters when a show has a
time loop structure since relationships
are constantly being reset and it's
mainly up to the main character to carry
all the developments himself so while
I've mentioned all the good things about
subaru has a character and how his
development is what makes the show such
an endearing watch my biggest gripe is
that his central driving force for
anything he does his love for Emilia
makes no goddamn sense were given very
little reason as to why he fell so
deeply in love pretty much immediately
especially when she doesn't even stand
out from the rest of the female cast
I mean sure she's the first one to help
him out and she's nice and uh you don't
talk about media like that okay
soon as small I ready to [ __ ] propose
gonna this smile he just wants to see a
smile oh and she can smile [ __ ] yay
it's a problem because pretty much every
action he takes in the entire course of
the series revolves around her he
blindly white knights her harder than a
horny teenager at a game ago convention
and because of this a final few episodes
of the show suffer and instead of
building up to a proper emotional climax
it kind of just feels cheesy and forced
and are you an absolute [ __ ] idiot
Subaru overall though re0 was an
enjoyable ride throughout and one I
definitely recommend watching the
splatter flaws with his characters and
plot the staff have done a fantastic job
with the source material they were given
resulting in a show that looks great
sounds great and to its credit contains
one of the best episodes of anime I've
seen in a while that had my jaw on the
floor it's definitely not as deep or as
fleshed out as it pretends to be as once
the shock of area ven wears off there's
nothing much else to carry it but that
doesn't stop it from being really
entertaining when you're watching it so
yeah that was pretty much it but if like
me you're tired of seeing best car
Subaru suffer so much I just wished he'd
save us all the household and just jump
off the planets already so he can
restart again well I have just figured
out the perfect way to cheat the system
whoops hey guys unfortunately my
camera's broken so no on-camera
appearance today but thank you very much
this month - Craig Watson shameless now
cam and everyone else on patron for
sports me in making this video possible
rezero is also available in crunchyroll
so you can go to controller comm /e
anime zone for a free month of premium
membership and if you're new here you
can check out my other stuff in links
here or follow me on twitter and
facebook anyway that's it for me today
I've been gig up and I'll see you all
next time